central Italy we have this continually
accept stroke as in quake and many of
our building has been damages and my
notes still is under that roof that fall
down in my office and so so this is the
story in Camerino and I hope that
something else to go on with the proper
support so the the talk will be about
compositionality for complex systems
through topology of data this work is
within a framework of data mining that
in which we propose a new approach based
on the fact that starting from a space
of data we can construct a combinatorial
topological object and this topological
combinatorial topological object that we
call simplicial complex has been used as
the base base to fight to associate
block bundle of fiber so the the
approach resort what we call topological
field theory of data this is a work that
I work jointly with Mario resetti from a
size foundation and the main step is
that the
the embedding sorry the embedding of
data into our topological space that is
a simplicial complex allows has to
considering the complex as a base pace
for the block fire bundle that we attach
to each point of the simplicial complex
and I think that you can observe that is
something related to the first talk of
this morning so what we have to consider
is that if we are able to construct the
simplicial complex to attach the fiber
to each point and we are assuming the
existence of a field action we are able
to construct a gauge group that is made
by two parts one part that is a afraid
I'd to say is the semi direct product of
two groups but there is one part of the
of the action that is represented by the
base that can be seen as in terms of in
a simplest case
[Music]
combinatorial ablation and another group
that is the group of transformation
based on possible process algebra so
this combination allows you to see that
we have some part that represent the
global constrain the global invariance
given by the structure and another
component that represents the local
operational level of the complex systems
so in one structure that can be seen in
terms of a gauge theory we find the two
components entangled one each other and
the emerging feature of the data
represented by the day technically the
complex systems were shown to be
expressed the correlation function of
the theory so if we go back to the to
the talk up to today complex system can
be defined as being composed by many
known identical elements entangle in a
loop of nonlinear interaction and
characterized by the characteristic
emergence behavior so this is general
definition but this definition has to be
interpreted in terms of this
mathematical structure what I'm trying
to do now is to say quite apologies
important and very few minutes to say
what is important what is important to
construct the simplest complex so
topology is important because studies
the shape of a space and maps between
between them it's important because we
can study simultaneously global and
local feature of the geometric property
what qualitatively speaking
and also because allows us to construct
a simplicial complex starting from a
cetera set your collection of data also
using some approach that is not metric
sensible but is based on the use of
concept of parameter that represent the
proximity nearness that can be expressed
not enough specific metric but in any
magic that you can be using so the
construction of a simplicial complex can
be made by using the disk method so this
algebra method called persistent
homology that in a very simple step
allows to filter from a discrete set of
discrete points the meaning information
that can be useful for your analysis so
I just try to show you in a in a click
[Music]
how given a set of points how we can
construct the simply sure complex by
defining the exploding the nearness
between points so the problem regarding
the choice of D that is the parameter of
nearness it's a problem but to overcome
the problem we use all possible
distances in a way that we can decide by
analyzing the life span of the existing
of north ave no hole in in an engineer
dimensional space which will be the best
one that represent the information that
we want to analyze so barcodes
represents some invariants
watch me when you want this conjugate
was going to start adding I mean that
taking two points there is this kind of
nearness express by Dee Dee is just the
distance between two points in the inter
sense of the matrix that you are using
and so is not that close together but
they are measured at the wrist this
algorithm that is called battery sweeps
by which yes okay so when they are for
example if you take one of the algorithm
when they are intersecting that the
balls they becomes 1 over over past the
fact that a simplicial complexes be
gluing together points lines and three
angles so when two ball intersect for
example it means that you pass from two
points to one age so you are two
components that becomes one component
when you are three points then if the
three ball instead sex intersect the
three points becomes two components in
one components that is a triangle a
triangle in two-dimensional space for
delicate Cartesian one is it's a cycle
but when they are together they collapse
and becomes a phase and so and so forth
and you blew by using this kind of
intersection between balls that
represent the matrix so it was running
because I want to so now suppose that we
are able to characterize a topological
space by using the bar codes the bar
codes tells you how many holes is
present in the
in the oil in the topological space we
are not using Bettina Marcia but we know
that there is a an algebraic approach
persistent homology based on algebra
approaches so but consider one
considerations that we are going behind
the graph by using this approach we are
going beyond the graph information so
because graph allows us only to consider
connectivity centrality about the set of
points we are going beyond because we
are also considering now higher-order
feature that are represented by holes
but there is another invariant that we
consider important that is the language
of part that can be associated to a
topological space so in this case we
have seen also this morning that apart
in a topological space is a continuous
map from one starting point to an end
point into two parts are on the topic if
you can slide one party to the other one
also in a continuous way and they are
not tomo topic if between the two parts
there is some missing information in all
for example so we can see that we can
have many many kind of parts among which
cycles and loops the important thing is
that the Amitabha is an equivalence
relation over our space a topological
space and consider the two the two cycle
with we can we know from the fundamental
group that today are not on topic 1 each
other so the part can be composed the
composition is allowed the two part each
path as an orientation over the
but the part composite B is not on your
topic to be a but still they have a lot
of information so we have a lot of
information regarding loops and to
understand what information they old
just move to another representation
think about to have the space and label
the age of this space by a for a result
our age and be with the vertical change
and then try to introduce some relation
over this space so the relation allows
us to glue the upper corner to deliver
corner and so on if we get this kind of
surface in Dinah now try to glue the big
part so if we made this approach we will
get a new topological space in an i/o
dimension that is the dolls so the
tourists can be represent now by two
generators the two generators are the
tool cycle in this case in the case of
tourists the two cycle is not anymore
one single part but it's a member of the
class of cycles that characterize all
the space plus one new relation that we
have introduced while wrapping the space
that is can be seen in this presentation
group presentation so in this case the
two part becomes amo topic but why we
are interested to observe this
construction because if each equivalent
class of part can be considered as a
behavior of its members and the behavior
is
press internal processes we want to go
further and to try to interpret in terms
of the topological space a dynamical
system so in this case we check the same
spaces we try to observe how a given
vector can move over the space so we
think that this is a part and this part
can represent a transition from one
state to another state in the previous
construction we can think that the set
of parts that we can represent over this
space can have cycles or can add some
parts that stop on the boundary of the
the surface so in this case if we are
thinking about a system that the Wolves
can be considered the bound as some kind
of deadlock for the evolution of the
system this is just an interpretation
that we can put over the the dynamics
but what why so it this is something
that can be interpreted also in the
domain of the processes if they stop we
can think to make the same approach that
we did with the previous one so try to
label the space give some orientation to
the age and glow together to give rise
to a new space that is the space in this
case of a torus with two generators am
be in this case we are able to in a
trivial we are in a trivial case we will
see why we are in a trivial case but
even in a trivial case we are able to
classify the behavior at least
classes the most in three classes so the
three classes is the part that is o mio
topi to one point that is internal one
that is the part that in a previous
space allows to describe the dynamics we
have a part that to go around the truths
a solid disaster the Detroit and and the
other one that is around the whole so
these three different classes of
behavior allows us to and to at least
think how in building when associated
the fiber to each point there is some
constraint given by the whole that
affect the dynamics of the systems and
if we want to use this approach for
describing the dynamic of the system we
have to be able to describe in a more
complete way how one state can be
transforming another state take into
account of the topology of the space so
the topology of the space ego is it
might be what you are looking for when
some of your combination is not allowed
is inconsistent the another important
thing is that during the transformation
from one state to another state the
error is something that is important
into theory because the hell represent
the Obrador that allows to the term what
will be the dynamics so the error
represent what I was previously
indicated with the transformation from
what stage one
state but it's not a transformation is a
call it is a set is a collection of
operators that can be applied over the
new space this is more complicated
example the one is a trivial one this is
a more complex and we have tried Mario
astride o to represent to represent the
all the relation that must be satisfied
when the manifold is three Teresa and
this is an example for the group of G
168 oh so you just just to tell you that
when we are characterizing the operator
it becomes very difficult to F to work
with all the set of transformation but
looking into this sorry looking into
this image perhaps we can rephrase a bit
the principle of flag for the flag
principle for compositionality because
we are not anymore in a linear
composition we are in a nonlinear
composition the non-linearity is given
by the topology of the space so there is
the non-linearity in our cases the
policy of the space but we could speak
about the global context where the the
dynamics of the system or the
interpretation of a complex system has
been made so the non-linearity is given
also within the composition if we go
back and I will run at the end if we
will go back to the standard frag
principle and we
just consider the same problem man in
terms of interpretation of regular
expression as non deterministic systems
we can observe that in as my knowledge
there is no axiom system that can be
proved up to by simulation that this two
term are by similar this is recall to
the work of mill 90-94 in which the
beautiful work in which it is thought
considering regular expression as non
deterministic systems it comes out with
a theorem to thehre me at the end of the
article that not every experience as a
star behaviors in terms of not every
recursive specification can be expressed
in terms of star behavior regular
expression especially those
specification that is are characterized
by infinite behavior and if we with
rethink these two terms in terms of the
theory that I introduced before we could
be able to reinterpret the concept of
cons of process within the framework of
topological space in this case the the
approach the interpretation of processes
in the topological field theory is
nothing but an application in
application where we can observe we can
represent the processes by using the
quiver we can associate to the quiver
naturopathy algebra and the quiver
represents the basis over which we can
define the old a transfer
maisha okay so I finish and justice
catch the point processes that we were
quiver with the set algebra the third
point is to identify Delhi algebra that
can be given within the space of the
given pathology bruh and then we define
the algebra in an OPS algebra because we
need Abby algebra to go from global to
local also in this case and to project
the two components when we finish to
represent the interpretation of
processing in this new schema we could
be able to reinterpret some of the
results that were given after the
mineral work and the interpretation
could help to understanding this
conjecture that corradini gave telling
that the set of regular expression
without zero with higher edited not
empty world property is the largest
language for which by Somali shall meet
a finite equation axiomatization so this
means that not a ready data emptied war
property is each star behavior must have
avoid to end in a pure cycle it means
infinite behavior and also there has to
be some escape and so so thank you and
sorry if I went over the time
[Applause]
so are there any questions please so the
points in your that represents your
complex system what do they actually in
the in the general theory can represent
any any information in the specific case
represent state so you only know matrix
you don't anything else just not the
disturbances in the in the specific case
we are not using the persistent homology
to build our structure because we are
using the quiver represent so of course
if we are coming from a generous space
if we are using the persistent apology
but we represent the scaffold of the
topological space like by using your
Quivers that is a multi directed graph
which we have the bottle jabra know it's
an application of the idea is not
general
ok questions
[Applause]